I've been doing a ton of videos on the
mechanics of taking the Laplace
transform but you've been sitting
through them always wondering what am i
learning this for and now I'll show you
at least in the context of differential
equations and I've gotten actually a
bunch of letters on on the Laplace
transform what does it really mean and
and all of that and those are excellent
questions and you should strive for that
it's hard to really have an intuition of
the Laplace transform in the
differential equations context other
than it being a very useful tool that
that that converts differential or
integral problems into algebra problems
but I'll give you a hint and if you want
a path to learn it in you should pursue
learn about Fourier series and Fourier
transforms which are very similar to
Laplace transforms and that'll actually
build up the the intuition on what the
what the frequency domain is all about
anyway let's actually use a Laplace
transform to solve a differential
equation and this is one we've seen
before so let me see let me here there
it is okay so let's say the differential
equation is y prime prime plus five
times the first derivative plus 6y is
equal to zero and you know how to solve
this one but I just want to show you
with a fairly straightforward
differential equation that you could
solve it with the Laplace transform and
actually it you end up kind of having a
characteristic equation and the initial
conditions are y of 0 is equal to 2 and
Y prime of 0 is equal to 3 now to you to
use the Laplace transform here we
essentially just take the Laplace
transform of both sides of this equation
so we get let me use a more vibrant
color so we get the Laplace transform of
Y the second derivative plus well we can
say the plus transform of 5 times y
prime but that's the same thing as 5
times on applause transform of Y prime Y
prime
plus six times the Laplace transform of
Y and let me ask you a question what's
the Laplace transform of zero let me do
that in a so the Laplace transform of
zero to the integral from 0 to infinity
of 0 times e to the minus stdt so this
is a zero in here so this is equal to
zero so the Laplace transform of zero is
zero and that's good because I didn't
have space to do it at all another
another curly L so what are the Laplace
transforms of these things well this is
where we break out one of the useful
properties that we learned and that
useful property let me write it over
here because I think that's going to be
some I'll need as much real estate as
possible let me erase this so what is so
we learned that the Laplace transform
I'll do it here actually I'll do it down
here the Laplace transform of F prime or
we could even say Y prime is equal to s
times the Laplace transform of Y minus y
of 0 right we we prove that to you and
this is extremely important to know so
let's see if we can apply that so the
Laplace transform of Y prime prime if we
apply that that's equal to s s times the
Laplace transform of well go from Y
prime to Y you're just taking the
antiderivative so putting the
antiderivative Y of the second
derivative we just end up with the first
derivative minus the first derivative at
0 notice we're already using our initial
conditions I won't substitute it just
yet and then we end up with plus 5 times
I'll write it every time just so that we
did this just a weekend so plus 5 times
the Laplace transform of Y prime plus 6
time's the Laplace transform of Y all of
that is equal to zero so just to be
clear all I did is I expanded this into
this using this so how can we rewrite
the Laplace transform of Y Prime well we
could use this once again so let's do
that so this over here I'll do it in
magenta this is equal to s times what s
times the Laplace transform of Y prime
well that's s times the Laplace
transform of Y minus y of 0 right I took
this part and replace it with what I
have in parentheses so minus y prime of
0 and now I'll switch colors plus 5
times once again the Laplace transform
of Y prime we could use this again so 5
times s times the Laplace transform of Y
minus y of 0 plus 6 times the Laplace
transform I know space 6 times a little
plus I'll do it another line plus 6
times the Laplace transform of Y all of
that is equal to 0 I know this looks
really confusing but we'll simplify
right now we could get rid of this right
here because we've used it as much as we
need to so now we just simplify
I know it's using the Laplace transform
we didn't have to guess at a general
solution or anything like that even when
we did characteristic equation we
guessed what the original general
solution was now we're just taking
applause transforms and let's see where
this gets us so simplifying actually
just want to make clear because I know
it's very confusing so this so I rewrote
this part as
this and I rewrote this thing as this
and everything else is the same but now
let's simplify the math so s tight so we
get s squared s squared times the
Laplace transform of Y I'm going to
write smaller I've learned my lessson
minus s times y of 0 s times y of 0
let's substitute Y of 0 here y of 0 is 2
so s times y of 0 is 2 times s so 2's so
I distribute that s minus y prime of 0 Y
prime of 0 is 3 so minus 3 plus so we
have 5 times s times the Laplace
transform of Y so plus 5 s times the
Laplace transform of Y minus 5 times y
is 0 Y of 0 is 2 so minus 10 minus 10
right 5 times this is 2 right here so 5
times 2 plus 6 times the Laplace
transform of Y all of that is equal to 0
now let's group our Laplace transform of
Y terms and our constant terms and we
should be hopefully getting someplace so
let's see my laplace transform of Y
terms I have this one I have this one
and I have that one so what am I left
with so let me factor out the Laplace
transform of Y part so I get the Laplace
transform of Y that's good because it's
a pain to keep writing it over and over
times s squared plus 5 s
plus 5 s plus 6 plus 6 so those are all
my Laplace transform terms and then I
have my constant term so if see I have 1
St so minus 2 s minus 2 s minus 3 minus
10 is equal to 0 and what can we do here
well let's well this is interesting
first of all notice that the the
coefficients on the Laplace transform of
Y terms that those are that
characteristic equation that we dealt
with so much and that is hopefully to
some degree second nature to you so
that's a little bit of a clue and if
just if you want some some very tenuous
connections well that makes a lot of
sense because the characteristic
equation to get that we substituted e to
the RT and the Laplace transform
involves a very similar function but
anyway let's go back to the problem so
how do we solve this so we're and
actually let me just give you the big
picture here because it's a good point
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
solve this I'm going to say the Laplace
transform of Y is equal to something and
then I'm going to say boy what functions
Laplace transform is at something and
then I'll have the solution if that
confuses you just wait and hopefully
it'll make some sense from here until
that point is just some fairly hairy
algebra so let's let's scroll down a
little bit just so we have some
breathing room and so I get the Laplace
transform of Y times s squared plus 5 s
plus 6 is equal to let's add these terms
to both sides of this equation is equal
to 2 s plus 3 plus 10 oh that's silly
plus 13 this is minus 13 here a phone
call who's calling I think it's some
kind of marketing phone call anyway 2's
plus 13 and now what can I do well let's
divide both sides by this s squared plus
5 s plus 6 so I get the Laplace
transform the Laplace transform of Y it
equal to 2's plus 13 over s squared plus
5 s plus 6 now we're almost done
everything here is just a little bit of
algebra so now we're almost done we we
haven't solved for y yet but we know
that the Laplace transform of Y is equal
to this now if we just add this in our
table of our Laplace transforms we would
immediately know what Y was but I don't
see something or I don't remember
anything we did in our table that looks
like this like this expression of s I'm
essentially out of time so in the next
video we're going to figure out what
what functions Laplace transform is this
and it actually turns out it's a sum of
some of things we already know and we
just have to manipulate this a little
bit algebraically see in the next video